so I already love you I mean we all have
siblings right and that's our
relationship with all of them but I bet
you'll have some pretty good brother
stories yeah we do so there's five of us
and we're all brothers five there's five
boys yes your poor mother
yeah yeah there's no other way to say it
yep I mean but I just mean that's a lot
of boys yeah and we were house the best
way to look we weren't good kids
impressive yes we were we were there
might there might have been a few police
stops at our at our house gotta be quiet
you called him out he's now calling you
we both spent quite a bit of our youth
and adolescence running from the law and
one of us was like man I cannot do these
guys so I'm just gonna get involved any
stories on Dan like possibly Ricky moves
that he thinks he doesn't have but he
did make some rookie moves uh you know I
I'm certainly not gonna put him on the
spot in that way I'm gonna put him on a
spot in a different way and many times
when we get together as a family Dan's
the only one involved in law enforcement
and first responding and in the few
times that we've had a chance to talk
it's we he's been able to relay to us
that no matter how hard we try he's just
seen and done things that we'll never be
able to actualize and it's it makes me
feel distant points but at the same time
I love and respect the fact that he is
so dedicated to his job and his purpose
then he's honest enough to be like hey I
know you're gonna try to relate to me on
this level but what I've seen you have
no idea what I go through every day and
I just want to be able to to lean on my
brothers and sisters-in-arms to do that
so that's kind of that's a difficult
space for us but it gives me I I texted
him the other day and we have a very we
grew up in like a man's man house and
it's not we don't show emotion that well
and all that and I've had to learn to
unhard wire those things
great thank you thank you but uh one one
thing I truly love about Dan is he as
much of the job that is difficult to
digest
he loves his work and he never once
takes it home with him and he's a
wonderful father and a wonderful husband
and a wonderful brother and to be able
to manage all that I can't even manage
my own life and for him to be able to
manage all that is super key to be here
and literally when your producers like
we're thinking to maybe getting your
brother down and I came up with a bit
making fun of me by the way cuz I told
just a bit of time but I didn't think he
would go because he's often so dedicated
to his department into his work and I
think it's awesome that in meeting a lot
of first responders in in doing this
film that we got coming up we're going
to talk about it later but every so
often whenever you get to talk to him
they want their department and they want
their unit showcased but they never care
to be like hey I did this so I good on
my brother for doing the bit but he's
always department and unit first above
all else yeah I think that is because in
difficult and forgive me if I'm speaking
out of terms but in difficult times
especially in subject matter that we
can't relate to you folks lean on each
other and I think that's very special
you have your family a bond then you
have your family which is really really
special
you're not only a first responder you've
actually your life has been saved by
first responder yeah yeah what happened
well back home I used to work for a few
different agencies and when I was
employed for the town of Newberry I was
just working just to have the Super Bowl
Sunday back in 2007 and I just took a
right on a route one and I started
heading northbound and my cruiser
I reached 25 miles an hour and next
thing I know I get hit head-on at 76
miles an hour by a fourth time drunk
driver
it took me cook me out of the game for a
little while yeah and that's that's a
picture what's left of that cruise I had
about 2,500 miles on it when I was
driving it so yeah it got banged up
pretty bad I was very lucky to get out
of there in whatever shape I'm in now I
only broke my left leg which is pretty
amazing you'll get a devastation done to
that car and you think it could have
been a lot worse if not you know life
ending I'm glad it was only your leg
though you're right you got lucky
because I saw the car yeah so that's a
great look but you are saved by first
responders absolutely yeah they're right
down the road from me and we're able to
get me out of my car that was I couldn't
open the door because was crushing so
bad so one of our junior guys actually
came running up to me and ripped the
door open I went to go put pressure on
my leg to get out it just collapsed I
said hey I broke my leg and he dragged
me out and I broke my leg Wow
I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this